die grundrente kommt opposition und
wirtschaft lehnen sie ab doch die große
koalition feiert stehen mühsam
ausgehandelten kompromiss
neue eskalation in hongkong auf den
straßen läuft die polizei immer härter
gegen demonstranten durch
cyberkriminalität auf dem vormarsch
eine neue analyse des bka warnt die
steigende zahl digitaler geräte bietet
kriminellen immer mehr ziele
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am 11 november
die vom sport wenig später mit norbert
lehmann einstimmen doch von mir
millionen menschen können nicht von
ihrer rente leben frauen vor allem
obwohl sie ein leben lang als
friseurinnen oder reinigungskraft
gearbeitet und oft auch noch kinder
großgezogen haben das soll ein ende
haben ab januar 21 gestern einigte sich
die regierung auf die grundrente heute
stimmten auch die parteigremien zu david
sauer erklärt was geplant ist die
grundrente ist ein zuschlag für
geringverdiener mit mindestens 35
beitragsjahren auch jahre in teilzeit
kindererziehung und pflege von
angehörigen werden berücksichtigt bis zu
1,5 millionen menschen sollen sie ab
2021 ausgezahlt bekommen überwiegend
frauen
ein beispiel jemand hat 40 jahre zum
mindestlohn gearbeitet macht bislang 512
euro rentenanspruch mit grundrente sind
es 961 euro
es gibt freibeträge vollen anspruch
haben alleinstehende rentner deren
einkommen unter 1.250 euro im monat
liegt bei paaren sind es 1950 euro
alles darüber wird angerechnet als
einkommen gelten auch mieteinnahmen
kapitalerträge private und betriebliche
altersvorsorge
geprüft wird das durch einen
datenaustausch zwischen
rentenversicherung und finanzbehörden
vermögen und immobilienbesitz werden
nicht berücksichtigt die kosten 1 bis
1,5 milliarden euro im jahr werden aus
steuern finanziert es war eine schwere
geburt die grundrente lange hatten union
und spd darüber gestritten ob und wie
man den anspruch auf einen
rentenzuschlag prüfen sollte doch der
einigungsdruck war riesig das schicksal
der koalition hängt daran
in der union sind zwar viele aber nicht
alle glücklich mit dem kompromiss in der
spd dafür umso mehr
florian a am tag nach dem kompromiss
gilt es ihn zu verkaufen und hubertus
heil würde erst
sein 38 eine pressekonferenz so früh ein
eigenlob so nötig wie selten ein
sozialpolitischer meilenstein
die grundrente sorgt für mehr
leistungsgerechtigkeit und für mehr
sicherheit im alter gestern hatten sich
union und spd auf ebendiese grundrente
geeinigt für geringverdiener nach 35
jahren arbeit was heute sowohl fdp als
auch die grünen stört aus unserer sicht
sollte die grundrente schon nach 30
beitragsjahren nicht erst nach 35
beitragsjahren greifen ungerecht bleibt
es weil alle die bedürftig sind und
nicht 35 beitragsjahre haben gerade
durch den rost fallen bei dieser
regelung und keine hilfe bekommen
überzeugen müssen die koalitionäre
ohnehin noch die skeptiker aus den
eigenen reihen
vor allem in der cdu im bundesvorstand
heute drei gegenstimmen eine kleine aber
lautstarke minderheit aus junge union
und wirtschaftsflügel beide verärgert
dass das vermögen der grund
rentenbezieher nicht mehr überprüft
werden soll
es braucht aber eine
bedürftigkeitsprüfung das ist ein
deutsches sozialstaatsprinzip damit es
an diejenigen geht dies auch wirklich
benötigen und das fehlt die cdu
vorsitzende spricht zwar von
berechtigten nachfragen
doch auf den wirtschaftsflügel zu gehen
will sie nicht es geht nicht darum den
alten anderen flügel zu befriedigen
zuerst einmal geht es darum eine
sachgerechte lösung zu finden für die
bürgerinnen und bürger die davon
betroffen sind und die jetzt profitieren
das sind durchaus eine ganze reihe von
menschen leichter hat es heute die
kommissarische spd-chefin einmütig
billigt das präsidium den kompromiss für
die spd-spitze ein weiteres argument in
dieser regierung zu verbleiben
wie viele rentner gibt es überhaupt und
wie viel geld bekommen die im schnitt
die deutsche rente in zahlen ein
ausführlicher überblick in unserem
online angebot auf heute.de
die türkei hatte es lange angekündigt
nun macht das land offenbar ernst es
schiebt angebliche es anhänger ab auch
nach deutschland
einer soll bereits ausgewiesen sein die
bundesregierung betont er habe keinen
bezug zur terror miliz
neun menschen sollen in den kommenden
tagen folgen alle deutsche staatsbürger
die bundesregierung will nun von der
regierung erdogan mehr informationen
klaus brodbeck
politisch ist das reiner froh die türkei
schiebt deutsche mit angeblichem e s
bezug nach deutschland ab noch aber
handelt es sich offenbar nicht um
kämpfer der terrororganisation
es handelt sich dabei im wesentlichen
und frauen und kinder
wir sind zur zeit dabei weitere
informationen auszutauschen einige
könnten auslagern wie diesem stammen
im norden syriens wo kurdische kräfte
den ds besiegt hatten in auflösung seit
dem türkischen einmarsch genauere
informationen aber fehlanzeige deshalb
erwarte ich auch von bundesaußenminister
damit seinen guten kontakten die türkei
dafür sorgt dass wir nicht überrumpelt
werden
ich würde es nicht erpressen nennen aber
überrumpeln und ist es schon sollten
zahlreiche es kämpfe in kurzer zeit nach
deutschland zurückkehren während die
sicherheitsbehörden wohl bald
überfordert die opposition sagt das
problem ist hausgemacht
wir hätten die chance gehabt rechtzeitig
sie zurückzuholen das hat die
bundesregierung verpasst und nun sind
wir in einer ganz schwierigen situation
die wir dann noch bewältigen müssen was
die bundesregierung aber dringend tun
sollte ist diese rückkehr geordnet zu
regeln also nicht darauf zu warten dass
die leute sich sozusagen selbst auf den
weg machen und dann möglicherweise unter
dem radar der sicherheitsbehörden
bleiben rang ersetzt europa unter druck
berlin voran erdogan treibt den
politischen preis für zusammenarbeit
nach oben
die europäer sind empört es muss absolut
verhindert werden dass diese waren
wieder auf freien fuß kommen und das
macht man muss koordiniert werden nicht
von oben herab über befehle abonniert
werden
noch immer aber wird europa in
flüchtlingsfragen erpressbar
das bleibt seine schwäche erdogan dürfte
das nutzen die erschütternden fälle
sexuellen kindesmissbrauchs ans licht
gekommen in bergisch gladbach sie ziehen
immer größere kreise
nun hat die polizei weitere männer
festgenommen und noch mehr material
beschlagnahmt
es könnte aufschluss darüber geben was
denn
wann genau widerfuhr das jüngste ist
noch nicht einmal ein jahr alt
thomas münten berichtet in den letzten
zehn tagen hat die polizei sieben
weitere tatverdächtige festgenommen die
sich alle an den miss post schätzt des
mutmasslichen haupttäters beteiligt
haben sollen
immer mehr zeichnet sich ein netzwerk ab
in dem bilder und videos und sogar die
opfer getauscht wurden von bergisch
gladbach aus kommunizierte der mann nach
bisherigen erkenntnissen der polizei mit
komplizen und kunden in ganz nrw und
auch in wiesbaden den hessen
ich glaube dass wir momentan immer noch
am anfang der ermittlungen stehen was
die datenauswertung angeht was uns jetzt
aber auch zugute kommt sind weitere
beweismittel zum beispiel auch
einlassung von beschuldigten
zeugenvernehmungen spurenauswertung usw
und die führen dann weiter zu anderen
beschuldigten und zu entsprechenden
strafprozessualen maßnahmen
zwölf opfer konnte die polizei bislang
identifizieren überwiegend die eigenen
kinder oder stiefkinder der mutmaßlichen
täter 150 polizisten werden nun die
daten aus bis zu zehn terabyte müssen
angesehen werden
das sind rund viereinhalb jahre
videomaterial allein die zahl der
beteiligten an den verbotenen chat
gruppen überrascht die ermittler das
lässt sich im moment noch nicht
abschätzen wir haben einen beschuldigten
bei dem diese beteiligung an chats bei
über 1000 liegt aber wir kommen auch auf
andere jets die wir auswerten müssen auf
weiteres datenmaterial und in so
verlässlich der umfang noch gar nicht
abschätzen
die staatsanwaltschaft rechnet mit
weiteren festnahmen in den nächsten
tagen ins ausland nach spanien
auch die neuwahl gestern hat nichts an
der politischen blockade geändert weder
das linke noch das rechte lager hat eine
mehrheit
die sozialdemokraten von
ministerpräsident sánchez holten mit 28
prozent die meisten stimmen auf dem
zweiten platz landeten die konservativen
mit knapp 21 prozent massiv zulegen
konnten die rechtspopulisten
sie sind jetzt drittstärkste kraft
spanien steht also wieder vor einer
schwierigen regierungsbildung
bolivien kommt auch nach dem rücktritt
von präsident evo morales nicht zur ruhe
in weiten teilen des landes gab es
wieder unruhen busse wurden in brand
gesetzt geschäfte geplündert
morales war mehr als 13 jahre lang an
der macht und boliviens erster indigene
präsident der sozialist bekämpfte armut
und inflation ließ straßen bauen und
wurde als idol verehrt doch er setzte
sich über die verfassung hinweg als er
zum vierten mal zur wahl antrat
christoph rath über ein zerrissenes land
es beginnt mit einem raunen in der menge
dann bricht ungebremster jubel aus die
meldung vom rücktritt von präsident
morales erreicht die straßen von la paz
nach wochenlangen protesten gegen seine
nach ansicht von beobachtern
manipulierte wiederwahl hatte er
zunächst neuwahlen versprochen wenige
stunden später dann aber seinen
rücktritt erklärt und dabei der
opposition einen putsch vorgeworfen
bestimmte kräfte haben immer mehr gewalt
und aggression geschürt und aus diesem
und vielen anderen gründen trete ich
hiermit zurück den letzten anstoß
braucht er kurz zuvor der armeechef der
dem präsidenten unmissverständlich
empfahl sein amt abzugeben
in den letzten tagen hatten sich die
proteste immer weiter verstärkte doch
auf den staatsapparat ausgeweitet
polizisten meutern
wir sind mit dem volk heißt es immer
wieder
mit morales geht nach 13 jahren der
erste indigene präsident lateinamerikas
mit seinen sozialistischen reformen
verbesserte er die lage vieler doch in
den letzten jahren regierte er zunehmend
autokratisch in der nacht gibt es
schwere unruhen anhänger sowohl von
morales als auch von der opposition
berichten von brandanschlägen auf ihre
häuser
auch am morgen gehen die ausschreitungen
und plünderungen weiter noch compo
libyen wohl nicht zur ruhe
seit monaten gibt es in hongkong
proteste gegen die regierung jetzt hat
sich die lage in den vergangenen tagen
noch einmal verschärft wieder wurde ein
mann von der polizei angeschossen die
zusammenstöße zwischen demonstranten und
den sicherheitskräften werden immer
heftiger
hongkongs regierungschefin lahm sagte
sie werde sich dem druck nicht beugen
stephanie schöneborn berichtet dieser
tag in hongkong beginnt mit
straßenblockaden es ist der tag an dem
die protestler die operation morgen
durchführen und es ist der tag an dem
die gewalt eskaliert auf beiden seiten
ein polizist in bedrängnis schießt einem
demonstranten in die brust der
unbewaffnet auf ihn zugeht
der 21-jährige wird schwer verletzt sein
zustand ist kritisch und die hongkonger
sind wütend jeder hier verlangt eine
erklärung von der polizei nicht mehr von
der regierung denn die polizei ist
längst nicht mehr unter der kontrolle
der regierung
die polizei macht ihr eigenes ding und
reagiert überzogen extrem die bringen
unsere leute um nicht nur die jungen uns
alle zur mittagszeit kommen
geschäftsleute raus demonstrieren
gemeinsam mit vermummten aktivisten bis
die polizei sie mit tränengas und
gummigeschossen verjagt und die wut der
menschen wird größer
einige kilometer von diesem protest
entfernt streitet sich ein mann mit
jungen leuten beschimpft sie sein kann
ich lesen jemand schüttet brennbare
flüssigkeit über den mann und zündete
ihn an auf sein zustand ist kritisch
ich werde jetzt eines klarstellen wir
werden keine mühen scheuen wege und
mittel zu finden um die ausschreitung in
hongkong so schnell wie möglich zu
beenden
as soon as possible dieser tag in
hongkong endet mit einem straßenkampf
die rufe nach demokratie und freiheit
gibt es noch doch hört sie kann mehr
großer feiertag heute in polen am 11
november 1918 wurde das land nach langen
jahren der teilungen und besatzungen
wieder unabhängig diesen tag nutzten
auch wieder nationalistische und
radikale gruppen in warschau nahmen
zehntausende teil die veranstaltung
richtet sich unter anderem gegen
migranten abtreibung und homosexualität
es gab auch gegen demonstrationen
bislang aber keine ausschreitungen
mit der wachsenden digitalisierung
wächst in deutschland auch die
cyberkriminalität
heute hat das bundeskriminalamt den
neuesten bericht dazu vorgestellt
die bandbreite ist groß sie reicht vom
ausspähen persönlicher daten über
einbrüche in netzwerke bis hin zur
verbreitung von schadsoftware
datenbetrug und digitale erpressung
im letzten jahr hat die polizei über
87.000 fälle von cybercrime erfasst
dominik löschmeister es ist nicht mal
ein jahr her da war der bundestag das
ziel von hacker-angriffen veröffentlicht
wurden persönliche daten von politikern
cyber kriminalität nimmt zu so das
bundeskriminalamt in wiesbaden neben
unternehmen und privatpersonen immer
wieder das ziel von kriminellen die
kritische infrastruktur deren ausfall
erhebliche folgen haben kann
das dunkelfeld ist immens wir sind uns
bewusst dass sowohl fallzahlen als auch
schadenssummen sowie die anzahl der
geschädigten weitaus höher sind als es
die polizeilichen statistiken ausweisen
können
viele unternehmen scheuen eine anzeige
weil sie um ihren ruf fürchten
cyberkriminalität hat 2018 an den
schaden von über 60 millionen euro
verursacht experten gehen aber von viel
höheren zahlen aus
gute nachrichten gibt es beim online
banking hier gingen die sogenannten
phishing attacken um 49 prozent zurück
auch für banken elektronisch aufgerüstet
haben generell sollten alle die im netz
unterwegs sind besser auf ihre daten
achten
wir können uns schützen indem wir zum
beispiel einfach so sicherheitsmaßnahmen
wie antiviren software auf unseren
rechnern installieren aber vor allem
unsere smartphones unsere laptops aber
auch alle anderen geräte die wir
mittlerweile in unserem vernetzten
zuhause haben mit allen updates versehen
die es gibt das bka geht von steigenden
straftaten im internet aus dafür wollen
die ermittler mehr personal einstellen
um die täter netz besser verfolgen zu
können
in australien hat der östlichen
bundesstaat new south wales den notstand
ausgerufen wegen verheerender waldbrände
mindestens drei menschen sind den
flammen bereits zum opfer gefallen
die feuer sind teilweise außer kontrolle
und bedrohen nun auch den großraum
sydney
heftiger wind und hitze schweren die
ohnehin riskanten löscharbeiten
tja und nun zur dir norbert und zur para
wm der leichtathleten in dubai mit der
dritten goldmedaille für das deutsche
team durch johannes floss der war
gestern schon im vorlauf über 100 meter
weltrekord gelaufen
im finale heute ein deutscher zwei
kampflos siegte felix strengen holte
bronze
er ist der klare favorit johannes flores
spätestens nach seinem weltrekord im
vorlauf zwei bahnen neben ihm sein
teamkollege felix strengen der einzige
der in diesem jahr auch schon unter elf
sekunden gelaufen ist
flores auf band vier streng auf 6 und
auf 7 das mit afrikanern longo zunächst
sind die drei in etwa gleich augen doch
dann rauscht johannes voss davon in
10,60 sekunden ist der vier zehntel
schneller als der zweitplatzierte mit
dem zielfoto gefunden werden muss silber
getauchten an den südafrikaner bronze
damit für felix strengen der sich mit
dem neuen weltmeister johannes voß über
zwei weitere deutsche medaillen freuen
kann
felix sondern südafrikaner waren auf
einmal vorneweg und neben ja dann war
mir klar jetzt muss ich die ruhe
bewahren und das konnte ich zeigen und
da eigentlich durchgesetzt seit drei
tagen immer mindestens ein mal gold für
das deutsche team so kann es morgen
gerne weitergeben
kevin krawietz andreas mies haben bei
den atp finals in london ihr erstes
gruppenspiel gegen das rumänische
niederländische duo deco er knapp
gewonnen der erste schritt in richtung
halbfinale
kempin krawitz und andreas mies in roth
brauchten etwas um ins spiel zu kommen
im tie break entschieden die shooting
stars dieser saison den ersten satz dann
aber für sich doch es blieb eng tv roja
die atp-finals sieger von 2005 10
hielten dagegen und gewannen satz nummer
2 im entscheidenden match tie break
waren die deutschen truppen
sensationssieger aber hellwach und
verwandelten ihren dritten matchball zum
7 6 4 6 und 10 zu 6
das war schon von mir danke norbert die
karnevals- und fastnachtshochburgen am
rhein sind ab heute wieder in der
sogenannten fünften jahreszeit
um 11 uhr 11 gegen das närrische treiben
los in mainz mit einem kräftigen in köln
gestarteten tausende jecken in die neue
session bestens gelaunt wurde
geschunkelt und gesungen
das wetter morgen macht nicht unbedingt
gute laune regen und schnee sind
angesagt die details hat gleich ist
intelli so viel von uns für den moment
das heute journal mit marietta slomka um
drei viertel 10
und an dieser stelle erwartet sie morgen
behalten danke dass sie dabei waren und
haben sie noch einen entspannten abend
tschüss
[Musik]
ein schokolade und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter ein neues tief über dem
vereinigten königreich das gibt neue
wolken zu uns und so gelangt regen und
der winzling aus dem südwesten wird er
kräftiger und teils stürmisch schauen
wir die kommende nacht und da wird es
recht durchwachsen seien vor allem im
süden viele wolken regen und schnee bis
auf etwa 500 meter
da müssen sie mit flocken rechnen im
nord westen werden die wolken dichter
und der wind weht aus südwest bei
temperaturen von minus ein grad im
vogtland und 5 grad zb an der ems im
tagesverlauf bilden sich schauer von
westen her da ist dann regen und schnee
dabei schnee auch im osten vor allem
nach süden hin dann in den
mittelgebirgen und an den alpen
schneefallgrenze um 500 meter nach
norden hin ist es etwas sonniger
zumindest zwischendurch einmal sonst
weht ein kräftiger süd bis südwestwind
temperaturen dazu erreichen zwei grad an
den alpen und 9 grad nach osten hin die
nächsten tage am mittwoch in der
südhälfte noch nass mit regen und schnee
sonst trocken weil ein bis sieben grad
ja und trocken wird es dann am
donnerstag und auch die sonne zeigt sich
hin und wieder mal damit einen schönen
abend